en este vídeo intentaremos calcular
6.742 por 23 así que como siempre pausa
el vídeo e intenta calcularlo por tu
cuenta bien vamos a trabajar juntos a la
forma de realizar esta multiplicación se
le conoce como el algoritmo estándar
algoritmo es una palabra elegante para
decir una serie de pasos a seguir o un
proceso para realizar algo tenemos seis
mil 742 por 23 así que escribiré el 23
en los mismos valores posicionales tengo
dos veces 10 así que escribiré el 2 en
el lugar de las decenas abajo de 4 veces
10 y 3 veces 1 en el lugar de las
unidades abajo de 2 veces uno quiero
recalcar que esta no es la única forma
de multiplicar números de hecho hemos
estudiado en otros vídeos distintos
métodos para realizar multiplicaciones
pero es importante darse cuenta
de lo que realmente está pasando y de
cómo en cierta forma todos esos métodos
hacen lo mismo aunque tal vez lo
escriban de maneras diferentes o se
realicen en distinto orden la forma de
calcular con el algoritmo estándar que
es muy probablemente la forma en la que
aprendieron tus padres a multiplicar
números de varios dígitos como estos es
multiplicar todos los números que hay en
seis mil 742 es decir todos los
distintos valores posicionales por tres
y después multiplicar dos por dos veces
10 y al final sumarlo todo así que
primero multiplicaremos por tres tengo
dos por tres es seis después tenemos
cuatro por tres lo cual es 12 y bueno se
dice que escribimos el 2 y llevamos una
pero realmente lo que está pasando es
que multiplicamos 4 veces 10 por 3 lo
cual es 12 veces 10 12 veces 10 puede
escribirse como 2 veces 10
bien eso es lo que pasa después tenemos
que 7 por 33 21 y tengo que sumar 1 que
llevábamos así que obtengo 22 pongo el 2
llevo 2 pero una vez más que acaba de
suceder bueno lo que hicimos fue
multiplicar 700 por 3 y eso me da 21
veces 100 más 100 que llevábamos es 22
veces 100 y esto se puede expresar como
dos veces 100 más dos veces 1000 por
último pero no por eso menos importante
6 por 3 es 18 más 2 es 20 recuerda
hablamos de miles así que esto es 20
veces 1000
ahora nos movemos a las dos decenas que
tenemos aquí así que dos por dos veces
diez es cuatro veces diez y tal vez
alguien quiere poner el cuatro aquí pero
esos no son cuatro veces diez cuatro
veces 10 se pone justo aquí es sólo
cuestión de práctica a las personas se
les enseña a poner un cero aquí si te
mueves al siguiente valor posicional
para no cometer este error bien sigamos
cuál es el resultado de 4 por 2 bueno es
8 lo escribiremos justo aquí porque
funciona
bueno estamos tomando 4 veces 10 por 2
veces 10 eso serán 8 x 10 x 10 lo que es
8 ps 100 después tengo 7 por 2 esos 14
que por supuesto podemos poner 4 y
llevamos 1 por así decirlo déjame
cancelar los números anteriores para no
confundirnos y por último tengo 6 por 2
que es 12 pero llevábamos 1 entonces
será 13 aquí lo tienes
ahora habrá que sumar cada lugar y
obtenemos que seis unidades más ser
unidades es 62 veces 10 más 4 veces 10
es seis veces diez o seis decenas dos
veces cien más ocho veces cien es diez
veces diez o lo puedes ver como 0 veces
cien o cero centenas y llevamos una una
vez 1000
una vez mil cero veces mil más cuatro
meses mil es cinco meses mil o cinco
unidades de millar dos veces diez mil
más tres veces diez mil es cinco meses
diez mil o cinco decenas de millar y por
último tengo sólo una vez cien mil o una
centena de millar así que mi respuesta
es 155 mil 66 y hemos acabado